plus de 70 ans d'existence et une
passion qui n'a pas pris une ride la
mobylette moyen de transport devenu au
fil des décennies objets de culte
continue donc d'attirer des foules les
foules à chaque rassemblement de
passionnés et quand la clé tourne la
fibre nostalgique vibre exemples lors du
retro Chinon mob avec Faustine lino et
clémenced
[Musique]
300 mobylettes sont arrivés en un
concert de pétard ce dimanche à Chinon
le tout dans une odeur d'huile et
d'essence une grande messe de passionnés
réunis le temps d'un week-end celui du
rétro chinomoba un rassemblement inédit
décidé sur un coup de tête par un mort
du 2 cyclo polémique cornette
un peu sur un délire sur voilà le but de
faire un gros rassemblement de
passionnés de de rencontres etc parce
que tout le monde se connaît mais qu'à
travers les réseaux sociaux en fait donc
là c'est mettre des visages sur les
prénoms c'est 32 départements
aujourd'hui qui sont descendus à Chinon
donc ça part quand même de Marseille
ou sinon en passant par Dunkerque etc
une panoplie de modèles était exposée en
randonnions de la mythique peugeot 103 a
des destriers aux couleurs flashy les
becanes traversent les époques et leurs
amateurs aussi passion on va dire
d'enfance parce que je suis né entre
guillemets
dans le métier depuis tout petit et puis
bon bah le virus a bien pris et donc je
l'ai transmis à mon fils qui est à ma
gauche en terme d'odeur c'est vrai
heure du deux temps surtout moi là
j'étais avec un ancien véhicule qui
roule pas vite entre guillemets donc
j'en ai bien profité le succès a été au
rendez-vous au point de devoir refuser
des inscriptions ce n'est que partie
remise le festival qu'on augmenté sa
jauge dans les prochaines années